on dit est hyperactif il est TDAH avec
impulsivité et en plus il est un pied
plat valgus très prononcé donc il a une
démarche un peu particulière c'est ça et
de temps en temps il a mal et quand il a
quand il souffre exactement il marche
encore moins bien voilà il marche il est
beau il boit un peu un petit peu de
sport
regardez cette vidéo
comment vous avez appris la régression
de parce qu'il y en a eu une autre une
seconde agression après ça c'est là
c'est la deuxième en fait ça a commencé
le jeudi et donc un groupe de jeunes
voulaient la cigarette électronique de
mon fils et ils l'ont poussé contre un
homme rébus et mon père qui passait
vraiment par hasard qui a un ancien
policier dire son ami oh là là il y a un
jeune qui va se faire lyncher j'y vais
enfin je vais arrêter ça les boxs
les jeunes sont partis et puis il y
avait dit bon monde dans la voiture je
te ramène donc moi il m'en parle donc
bon je me suis dit c'est une histoire
parmi tant d'autres donc j'ai pas porté
plus attention que ça je vais demander
ce qui s'est passé il m'a raconté j'ai
dit bon bah ça va peut-être
pas répondre surtout ce qui a pas
longtemps il était encore puni quand il
se défend
donc
et lundi le lycée m'appelle
déjà il y a le vendredi parce que mon
père le sentait pas et dit il dit mon
petit frère vient on va aller chercher
Rudy on va aller manger avec lui et on
va le ramener après et il a vu c'est ce
groupe de jeunes aller vers rudi et
quand ils ont eu la voiture elle est
sortie on a quand même un qui est monté
sur le capot de mon père quand même
ah oui
on rigole mais c'est n'importe quoi et
donc derrière et donc il est sorti et
donc il y a rien eu le vendredi et le
lundi c'est la CPE m'appelle en disant
votre fils vient d'être prêt à partir
par plusieurs jeunes mais sans dehors du
lycée donc ça nous regarde pas alors là
j'ai dit j'en avais vraiment marre et je
voulais que j'allais porter plainte
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous aviez
vous aviez tiré la sonnette d'alarme
avant il y avait déjà eu des prêts
il y a beaucoup une bagarre déjà l'année
dernière et comme mon fils répond il se
fait bah exclure en même temps c'est ça
c'est ça donc on me dit oui certes ça
veut dire est victime mais vu qu'il a
répondu il devient plus victime et ce
qui subit au quotidien
d'handicapés de canard boiteux et on
l'énerve assez facilement puisque mon
fils est impulsif donc
c'est insupportable d'aller à l'école à
Port au ventre de de se dire tous les
jours je vais vivre des moments
invivable à
[Musique]
il doit se laisser donc bousculer
agresser insulter
faut voir comme combien de fois une
lettre cassé
et ça c'était dans l'enceinte de
l'établissement
que oui voilà
c'est Rudy c'est Rudy
il faut pas qu'il réplique Rudy réplique
trop donc ce jour-là quand l'agression
est mieux qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il
aurait dit venu rentrer à la maison
après il vous aura plu
c'est mon père qui l'emmenait à
l'hôpital parce que moi j'ai les autres
enfants à la maison j'ai pas pu y aller
combien d'enfants
après d'accord et donc quand vous avez
su qu'il avait été agressé déjà ça a été
quoi votre votre réaction
j'ai pas vraiment
portable je suis dit c'est encore une
bagarre de plus j'ai dit et là j'ai dit
à Rudy bon faut que tu arrêtes faut
vraiment que tu arrêtes il faut que tu
te calmes il faut donc même moi je joue
dans le jeu quoi pour lui c'est la
triple peine ah oui non mais je m'en
rends compte je me suis je me mange
enfin aujourd'hui donc tu m'en veux
énormément d'ailleurs
j'y suis pour rien j'ai dit oui mais
calme-toi
il me l'a envoyé par WhatsApp comment il
vous a envoyé ça en mettant quoi comme
agression
c'était comme ça c'était le mardi qui me
l'a envoyé il retourne à l'école depuis
il y était le lendemain
il a vu un journaliste venir au lycée et
là il a attrapé le père
aujourd'hui comment il va alors
physiquement ça va franchement
physiquement mais psychologiquement
c'est compliqué il veut pas sortir tout
seul
donc
[Musique]
psychologiquement c'est très dur
psychologiquement c'est très dur il veut
pas sortir tout seul je suis obligée de
l'accompagner quand j'étais à l'hôpital
aux IMJ pour faire séjours il est sorti
et puis rentré par peur dans la voiture
en me disant maman ils sont là ils sont
là ils sont là mais c'est pas possible
ils sont en garde à vue
facilement voilà
localisable ou si on peut facilement les
tout le monde n'a pas été interpellé la
manque deux est-ce que vous avez essayé
un moment parce que ça serait ça se
répète depuis plusieurs semaines il me
dit qu'il y a eu beaucoup de problèmes
avec les lunettes cassées si vous
essayez un moment de joindre les parents
de non jamais jamais juste école et
l'école
le lycée ou les avait joints plusieurs
fois on leur dit non
vous avez pas eu le le directeur de
l'école proviseur
pénalement il y avait une enquête donc
pour l'instant elle était pas vraiment
courant d'affaires mais est-ce que vous
avez dit comment se fait-il que mon fils
revienne tout le temps avec ses lunettes
cassées il est la boule au ventre quand
il va à l'école et que aujourd'hui il
est en situation de handicap non on
parlait pas tout ça puisque mon fils ne
parle pas donc on peut pas deviner ce
qui ce qui ressent en fait
des agressions on savait on savait qu'il
répondait qui se défendait mais il en
disait pas plus et
je l'ai retrouvé en pleurs dans le lycée
caché dans un sur un banc et avec une
surveillante on l'a retrouvé en pleurs
où il a craqué il a dit maman j'en ai
marre à chaque fois que je me défends
dit que c'est moi que c'est moi mais
c'est pas moi mais il a quand même eu
deux jours d'exclusion
[Musique]
mais malheureusement quand il y a une
histoire comme ça on redit c'est une
parole contre par exemple deux trois
personnes qui vont dire la même chose
donc forcément Rudy a tort
aujourd'hui
Rudy il va retourner l'école quand alors
il a arrêté pour l'instant jusqu'au 14
malheureusement il veut retourner
à l'école il veut pas y retourner il
veut pas y retourner il veut pas
retourner dans cette école pour le
comprendre ah mais je le comprends
puisqu'il y a quand même deux personnes
qui se sont qui sont pas interpellés
donc on lui demande de retourner à
l'école de les voir et en plus il est
quand même la risée de son lycée faut
savoir que les vidéos ils ont tourné ils
se sont moqués de lui ils se sont en
disant qu'il était même pas capable de
se défendre qu'il était même pas capable
de défendre contre une fille
ce qui est la deuxième agression le même
jour
par combien de personnes ils étaient 4 5
il y a une deuxième agression c'est ça
le même jour le même jour deux heures
après parce que là ce qu'on a vu c'était
la deuxième agression c'était la
première de la journée il y a une
deuxième c'est ça on a une deuxième
regardez les films à chaque fois en plus
[Musique]
incroyable
et le chef d'établissement il a vu c'est
dans l'école dans son école
il a pas honte en fait avoir laissé ça
s'installer comme ça
c'est un soutenable alors tu sais c'est
pas mon fils pour vous c'est c'est
très compliqué
c'est très dur c'est très dur parce que
j'aurais préféré être à sa place en fait
j'aurais dû le défendre plus en fait
j'ai pas compris j'ai pas j'ai pas
réalisé
vous alerter plusieurs fois et
même moi j'ai pas compris j'aurais dû
être plus ferme j'aurais dû être plus
dur
et aujourd'hui je m'en excuse je
m'excuse auprès de mon fils
on comprend et bon après vous avez
[Musique]
traumatisme elle a 8 ans j'ai une autre
fille qui est au collège on l'a
clairement l'embêté on l'a menacée en
lui disant tu vas finir comme ton frère
j'ai dû enfin j'ai dû tout de suite
mettre Léo là tout de suite allez
recevait des messages en disant que
voilà tu finir comme ton frère que
c'était une [ __ ] qui était même pas
capable de se défendre donc elle a
craqué elle a pleuré elle a 12 ans
vous avez de conscience qu'aujourd'hui
c'est je comprends pas moi quand
j'entends votre témoignage je comprends
pas comment
les le proviseur du lycée la CPE ne se
dit pas on va vraiment tout faire pour
qu'ils se sentent bien avec nous ou bien
que les autorités disent voilà qui va
changer d'école on va on essaie de
trouver un lycée au plus vite c'est
vraiment c'est c'est catastrophique
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a des lycées
à côté de chez vous donc
c'est tous les lycées sont loin donc
c'est pour ça que je demande un taxi
MDPH jusqu'à la fin de ses études enfin
de l'accompagner aujourd'hui le 14 il
retourné à l'école il va retourner ou
pas au lycée actuelle pas ce lycée là en
tout cas de toute façon même si je
l'obligerai chose que je le ferai pas il
irait pas il va sécher il va aller
dehors il va se cacher et j'irai pas il
m'a dit mais moi je n'y retournerai pas
donc là vous allez laisser je veux pas
qu'il arrête ses études il a toute sa
vie devant eux devant lui il faut pas
qu'il arrête ses études
il vous demande quoi aujourd'hui c'est
quoi son cri d'alarme il vous dit il
demande à changer de lycée
au cap il est loin de chez vous un aussi
un autre
2h
toute la famille non c'est pas possible
c'est un problème quand même insoluble
c'est donc il faudrait qu'il y ait
vraiment qui a un taxi tous les jours
deux heures
mettre maillot
d'effet répéter dans le sud de menaces
et du harcèlement caractérisé ça
alors ça l'est depuis un an et vous avez
une réaction mais tous ici autour du
plateau qui est bonne logique à l'école
pourquoi ça marche pas pourquoi on fait
pas venir les parents pourquoi il y a
pas de table ronde pourquoi en fait on
dit pas il y a de la violence je la
reconnais c'est pas exactement le
parking en fait de l'école c'est pas
dans l'école en fait c'est juste à côté
c'est le parking voisinant l'école ce
sont des personnes qui sont dans l'école
ça vient de bien sûr ça vient de la
colle et que l'école le lycée en
particulier l'inspection académique ne
se cessent pas du problème d'ici il y a
pas un problème il y a une
responsabilité là-dedans d'accord on y
arrivera peut-être judiciairement il
faut juste comprendre que ça peut
arriver à d'autres que il y a un moment
on fait une table ronde on discute du
problème dans l'école parce que c'est
aussi un problème de l'école ils sont là
pour renseigner ils sont là pour dire
les choses et ce serait une bonne chose
après on a entendu effectivement double
peine j'ai entendu voir triple peine
dans votre bouche mais c'est exactement
ça parce que c'est la victime qui s'en
va
on va inverser les choses on devrait
inverser les choses exactement cinq
personnes cinq personnes sont exclus
monsieur il arrive effectivement Rudy il
arrive il doit bien se sentir parce
qu'il fait des études sérieuses et qu'il
y arrive malgré son du Cap c'est ça
qu'on voudrait voir c'est ça qu'on
voudrait entendre ce que vous dites la
série que c'est fou c'est vous qui devez
trouver des solutions ils doivent vous
allez trouver un lycée à deux heures de
route alors que il y a 5 élèves 5
familles il suffit aussi de convoquer
les parents et de leur dire sinon voilà
dernière fois s'il y a encore un terminé
c'est fini on les sort du lycée on les
on les on les on les ailes c'est pas lui
qui doit quitter le lycée si vous
permettez j'ai encore mieux parce que
effectivement on va dénoncer des faits
qu'est-ce qui se passe derrière les
parents habituellement on ne couvre pas
les enfants ou en tout cas on va les
protéger et là on va les couvrir on
venant menacer ma cliente en disant
c'est pas normal il faut retirer votre
plainte parce que sinon vous allez voir
ce que vous allez voir il y a une plante
qui a été déposé contre une mère de
famille non si c'est vrai qui vous a
menacé qui vous a dit sinon vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir alors elles
ont commencé par s'excuser donc j'ai
trouvé ça super gentil de leur part je
leur ai dit et ils m'ont dit mais tout
ça c'est de la faute de Rudy tout ça
c'est de sa faute
quoi parce que c'est eux qui les cherche
et qu'il les traite et se protège en
disant que il a eu des propos racistes
voilà
ils ne sont pas confirmés par le
procureur
par le procureur
parce que je viens d'une famille qui est
multiracée
et mon mari et les deux couleurs et mes
enfants sont métisses donc c'est pas
possible
et ça m'étonnerait que on est d'accord
Emmanuel maillot je vous laissais le
goût de la fin pour noter les
spectateurs juste aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui va se passer alors nous on attend
au-delà de la réponse du lycée la
responsabilité du lycée au-delà la
responsable des parents qui est m'adapté
parfois mais qui il faut le dire sur les
cinq il y en a quand même qui sont
excusés c'est une réponse pénale on est
là aujourd'hui la réponse pénale c'est
aussi un problème on a parlé aujourd'hui
aussi dans votre bouche c'est pas normal
et c'est les victimes qui partent elles
devraient pas partir on a une réponse
pénale par exemple sur les femmes
battues sur en fait des concurrents
battus ou des époux ou épouses battus
on éjecte en fait monsieur ou le
conjoint violent directement désormais
il y a des il y a des systématiquements
poursuivis et Monsieur si c'est Monsieur
l'auteur défaire en fin de garde à vue
il rentre plus chez lui c'est terminé et
là effectivement un contre judiciaire
direct j'aimerais bien que
systématiquement on est ça aussi chez
les enfants chez les mineurs on va dire
non mais il y a une version éducative
mais effectivement il faut ça nous on
attend ça on attend qu'effectivement il
ne rentre plus dans le lycée exactement
que ce soit Rudy qui soit à l'aise dans
son lycée la réponse pénale elle existe
et chez les mineurs c'est aussi un
problème parce qu'elle est longue nation
3 janvier 2023 c'est la date d'audience
choisie par effectivement le parquet en
tout cas le tribunal judiciaire le
Senlis 3 janvier 2023 et en plus vous
avez deux actions parce qu'ils sont
quatre effectivement qui sont prévenus
et deux sont à Beauvais et de 70 ça fait
deux audiences pour les victimes et
effectivement on privilégie le mineur
auteur du coup la victime elle a pas été
informée puisque c'est son conseil qui
décroche son téléphone pour savoir ce
qui se passe c'est ça aussi le problème
c'est que ce qu'il faut changer c'est ça
c'est l'information de la victime qui
doit prédominer effectivement après sur
pénale des mineurs ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui et on a une réponse pénale
on la voudrait beaucoup plus rapide